التباين سمه التنافس الانتخابي وهذه نظره
على ابرز الاختلافات بين مرشحي الجوله
الثانيه من الانتخابات الرئاسيه التركيه
نبدا مع وعود حمله رجب طيب اردوغان ومنها
صياغه دستور مدني جديده وتحقيق الاستقرار
السياسي والاقتصادي اقتصاديا يعد اردوغان
برفع الحد الادنى للاجور وزياده رواتب
المتقاعدين وتخفيض البطاله الى اقل من 5%
وابقاء التضخم في خانه الاحد من الوعود
الداخليه ايضا زياده فرص العمل واعطاء
تسهيلات نقديه للمواطنين وزياده القدره
الشرائيه لهم داخليا ايضا يسعى اردوغان
الى الاسراع بالعوده الطوعيه لمليون سوري
من خلال اتفاق مع الرئيس بشار الاسد وبشكل
موازن سيعمل الرئيس التركي حسب تصريحاته
على على الكفاءات من السوريين خاصه
الاطباء والمهندسين الذين حصل كثير منهم
على الجنسيه التركيه معتبرا طردهم عملا
غير انساني خارجيا وثق الرئيس التركي
علاقاته علاقات بلاده مع الصين وروسيا
ودعا لان تتبنى تركيا تحالفات متعدده
الاطراف ننتقل الى الضفه الاخرى ضفه
المعارضه ووعود لتشدار اوغلو اولويه
المعارضه داخليا هي اعاده نظام الحكم
الرئاسي الحالي الى النظام البرلماني
واستعاده منصب رئيس الوزراء اقتصاديا وعدا
كمال كريتشدار اوغلو بخفض التضخم عبر
اتباع السياسات الاقتصاديه التقليديه
واعاده الاستقلال للبنك المركزي ايضا من
وعود المعارضه توفير فرص العمل ومكافحه
الغلاء وجذب رؤوس الاموال العالميه اما
فيما يتعلق بملف اللاجئين السوريين فتدعم
المعارضه اعاده العلاقات مع سوريا لتوفير
بيئه امنه تشجع لعودتهم اضافه للوعد
باتمام عمليه الاعاده خلال عامين اما
خارجيا فاعلنت المعارضه ان اولويتها هي
عوده المفاوضات مع الاتحاد الاوروبي حول
انضمام تركيا للتكتل كذلك تسعى المعارضه
لتوجيه العلاقات نحو الغرب مره اخرى بما
في ذلك الولايات المتحده الامريكيه واعاده
تركيا الى برنامج طائرات الاف 35 المقاتله
التي استبعدت منه تركيا بعد شرائها دفاعات
صاروخيه روسيه لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات